ich bin schon sehr gespannt auf den
donnerstag im deutschen bundestag der
ukrainische präsident wohl otto mir
selensky wird sich an uns richten mit
einer live video schalte und die
zentrale frage ist doch dann natürlich
wie reagiert der bundeskanzler hält er
eine emotionale rede oder überhaupt
irgendeine rede oder gibt es eine
debatte zur ukraine das absurde ist
fehlanzeige
es folgt gar nichts diese ampel
koalition will tatsächlich nach der
ansprache von wolodimir selensky die
debatte zur tagesordnung übergehen
lassen und über die impfpflicht
diskutieren im us-kongress macht man es
anders im europäischen parlament hat man
es anders gemacht und wir verlangen dass
der bundeskanzler im parlament eine
regierungserklärung abgibt wir haben
immer gesagt die bundeskanzlerin hat im
parlament da hat die opposition
gefordert dass eine regierungserklärung
abgibt wenn sie nur einmal über brüssel
fliegt und sie hat es auch gemacht nach
jedem eu-gipfel und jetzt sehen wir
stolz duckt sich weg und ich finde das
ist zum fremdschämen
wenig wie könnte die führungsstärke von
herr scholz aussehen
also ich glaube dass das wäre schon
angemessen wenn wenn wir jetzt diese
historische rede haben werden und dies
jetzt soll ist nicht nur für uns sondern
auch für deutschland denn zum ersten mal
wird ein staatsoberhaupt
online vor den abgeordneten auftreten
eine rede halten ich glaube das wäre
schön dass man auch darauf reagiert im
anschluss vielleicht auch eine debatte
stattfindet und dass auch die regierung
eben den weg schildert also was was
geplant wird also etwas was die ampel
jetzt vor hatte um der ukraine zu helfen
also wir haben gehört die zeitenwende
wurde eingeläutet aber seitdem gab es
nicht viel was wir gespürt haben und
deswegen das glaube ich schon eine eine
wichtige botschaft aus berlin um eben
nicht nur gegenüber präsenz geht sondern
was ist was die menschen in der ukraine
erwartet werden das glaube ich das wäre
eine schöne gäste man muss sich das mal
vorstellen ich wills nur noch mal
unterstreichen die um die empörung wir
haben diesen krieg jetzt seit 20 tagen
die europa im kriegszustand und seite
regierungserklärung von scholz sitzt er
im parlament und sagt nichts den
diskutierten heute über die ukraine er
sitzt stoisch zuhört zuschickt annalena
baerbock vor und er
positioniert sich einfach nicht das
finde ich ist also unglaublich und das
geht auch völlig vorbei an den themen
die irgendwie die menschen zu hause
bewegen die europa bewegung die unser
land bewegen muss nein ich glaube
diplomatisch ist alles gesagt das geht
gar nicht es müsste natürlich die große
rede des bundeskanzlers von mir aus und
oder der außenministerin sein die dazu
bestellungen aber ich überlege mir auch
die ganze zeit würde ich mir das
versuche vorzustellen dieses waghalsige
terminplanung da unten ablauf was sendet
das auch für ein signal sendet auch das
signal dass dieses parlament und die
regierung quasi sich total anders
verhalten als jeder normale mensch sich
verhalten würde wir stellen uns mal vor
es sind menschen in einer freundin
freundeskreis beim abendessen und dann
kommt sagen wir mal der
oberbürgermeister dazu der kommt dazu
der spricht da und sagt etwas ganz
bedeutend ist und das die ganze stadt
von interesse sondern geht er wieder und
es gibt keine gruppe kein esstisch kein
stammtisch keinen freundeskreis der dann
sagt auf wiedersehen machen sie es gut
und zu seinen alten themen von vorhin
zurückkehrt sondern natürlich würde man
sagen das war toll das war wichtig das
hat uns herausgefordert da wollen wir
mitmachen so sehen wir dass das würde
man ja schon als guter gastgeber
eigentlich erwarten also das verstößt
gegen alle guten regeln des
zusammenseins und ist politisch ein
unglaublicher fauxpas möglicherweise
wird noch um gedacht bis bis zu dem
moment und und olaf scholz bewegt sich
dann doch gegen das protokoll und gegen
die dinge auf eigenes mandat ans
rednerpult und sagt etwas wir haben es
aktiv gefordert man hat es blockiert
aber das sind deshalb mehr denn ja es
ist doch absurd über die große
ministerin hat sich heute hingestellt
und sagt manchmal sei es besser
zuzuhören als nur zu reden ja natürlich
werden wir alle gebannt zuhören das
wären emotionale bord sein
aber dann nicht in die diskussion zu
gehen ist einfach absurd und ich finde
was aus sicht der menschen ich stelle
mir das auch vor wenn in einer live
übertragung im deutschen fernsehen die
leute sehen was präsident seelands
gesagt und dann wird das thema
impfpflicht ausgerechnet die impfpflicht
die diskussion die mit der korona
politik wollen jetzt monatelang stellt
die müttern hochgezogen darüber
diskutieren die abgeordnete dafür kann
niemand verständnis wir wollen hier
einmal paul ronzheimer der uns live aus
kiew zugeschaltet mit den diskussionen
rheine und paul meine frage ist die
direkt bei mir im kopf entsteht ist ist
es vielleicht auch strategie ist es
methodik damit wladimir putin vielleicht
ja nicht noch aggressiver wird also
machen die das vielleicht im bundestag
überlegt ein sind frau berbalk unter
scholz vielleicht überlegt und es soll
genau das signal gesendet werden was
damit gesendet wird es wird zugehört
aber wir sagen nichts
ehrlich gesagt fällt es mir schwer bei
dieser bundesregierung momentan an
irgendeine große strategie zu glauben
die dahinter steckt wahrscheinlich hat
das tatsächlich er mit traurigkeit zu
tun dass man da gar nicht dran gedacht
hatte dass das doch eine schöne idee
wäre da eine debatte zu machen und dann
hat das die opposition erkannt und dann
wollte man wahrscheinlich nicht
nachgeben und sagen ja mensch der märz
hat und zwar meistens nicht recht aber
hat zwar meisten verletzungen aber
diesmal diesmal schon so ich glaube so
einfach ist das auch finde immer noch
dass tatsächlich die art der
kommunikation von olaf scholz in dieser
krise wirklich ein problem darstellt
also man hat ja vorher immer gesagt toll
jetzt haben wir so ein kanzler der redet
genauso langweilig wie die kanzlerin so
und jetzt haben wir ein kanzler wo ich
mich manchmal frage ob er die leute
wirklich mit nimmt auch in dieser krise
und ob er wirklich einerseits denjenigen
die vielleicht eher skeptisch oder die
sicherlich gibt die skeptisch gegenüber
den sanktionen sind erklärt warum die
wichtig sind ein bundeskanzler der auch
erklärt was eigentlich in der spd los
war in den letzten jahren der auch mal
sagen kann seine partei hat große fehler
gemacht mit viel in der ukraine
ukraine krieg ein kanzler der
ehrlichkeit mit klaren worten klaren
ansagen an dem ich mich orientieren kann
das bürger und es gibt vielleicht noch
einen punkt also dem drängen der
opposition durch nachgeben ist
vielleicht tatsächlich angesichts der
größe des ereignisses bis hin zu kleinen
von mir vorhin auch schon selber
eingeflogen aber vielleicht ist es eben
ein beredtes schweigen weil er wird sich
gefragt haben was soll ich dann
eigentlich sagen ja wenn mich jemand um
hilfe bittet kann ich ja schlecht danach
sagen kommt aber nicht
also der moment wenn selensky mit dem
ihm eigenen
positiven partners und dieser
überzeugungskraft und dieser rhetorik
der gewinnenden rhetorik in der
situation eine bitte äußert muss man ja
eigentlich sagen ja da kann man auch
nicht sagen hatte denken wir jetzt mal
darüber nach sondern dann muss man
eigentlich eine antwort geben und wenn
man keine antwort hat schweigt man
vielleicht lieber aber ich stelle mir
trotzdem die situation morgen vor wir
haben ein bundestagspräsidium jetzt
schon mal sehr sehr reduzierten
bestandes sind jetzt corona bedingt nur
fromm göring eckardt und frau da ich
glaube frau göring-eckardt leitet dann
morgen früh die sitzung ich meine ohne
der jetzt despektierlich zu sein aber
was würde dann sagen herr präsident
danke für ihre worte wir wünschen ihnen
alles gute es ist also ist ja schon fast
galgenhumor aber ich finde das ist und
ohne unebenheiten
frau wird im zweifel auch sagen dass das
doch eigentlich ganz richtig ist was er
wladimir putin da sagt ja ganz so
schlimm die macht ihre amtsführung schon
ganz okay aber es doch auch absurd wenn
man sieht dann wie das läuft und was das
für ein signal auch an präsident
seelands käßmann heute im us-kongress
ich habe es jetzt am rande der
bundestagssitzung nur in der
berichterstattung verfolgen können diese
leidenschaftliche debatte die nach
seiner adresse dort im kongress gefüllt
wurde das ist es wie man es erwartet und
dann einfach zu sagen vielen dank alles
gute guten weg und tagesordnung ist eine
peinlichkeit schäme ich mich wirklich in
der außenwirkung auch ich hoffe wir
werden da müssen alle kameras voll
draufhalten und es dann auch
entsprechend würdigen